yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I
hope everything works fine let's go into
kick off this with couple of blitz games
yeah welcome to all of you in the chat
there on Twitch a couple of new Garcia
John suck turn yeah I know your name
from my video from a channel revolver
ocelot 92 it's a cool name and hello
also two fours illogical you have got
someone from the field of philosophy
here okay and karate meister 2003 okay
so i think the stream should be live
everything points toward that so I'm
going to kick up the kick-off kick up
kick off with a five minute game and see
what happens ya know to Calais yeah
Karim ass off I am let's see what
happens are from metal gear okay I never
played any of those games so I didn't
know that um ok so what to do here I
don't want to play the Bogle maybe
that's play Clara classical Queens
gambit yep also my green screen books
I've got a new green screen only today I
think this is a little bit better than
the other one even though that's the
room for improvement better light would
help but maybe I can improve that when
I'm when I finished moving to my new
place okay
my pd seven should work here still yeah
I'm fine thanks for asking busy day so
when see five-year and expanding on the
queenside quite a bit here mr. Karamazov
yeah I'm happily playing on quick a5
someone requests here Kellis 90 can i
play the selectors laughs today why
would you want me to play that opening
isn't that kind of passive I sometimes
play to passively anyway and now with
the selectors laughs I don't know
doesn't feel like a very attractive
proposition to me hmm really i thought
that this looks a little bit wrong like
like some awkward pinning business here
a group c aid or something like that
okay i go rook c8 the schlechter Slav
that is the Slav with e3 ng6 it's
difficult to force anyway so i don't
know if it's easy to get this opening in
the first place so what to do here
I got Bishop d7 they probably will play
92 and this is not leading to much
yeah somehow this doesn't feel so bad
for him which is kind of strange to be
honest hmm don't know maybe I can just
do this for 9 a-4 so kind of weird
revolver ocelot asked about the same
semi terrace that's a very decent
opening up and is it a good theoretical
state at the moment and can be played to
show okay I'm happy to get rid of that
LightSquared bishop them
cost some time okay taking it and now 94
maybe trying to activate now look to be
seven is something that could be
annoying I think 94 makes sense trombe
is a good is a good alternative if you
want an early offbeat deviation
drop-offs key is good the check benoni
is not such a terrible opening it is it
is somewhat better for why but it's not
it's not like it's completely unplayable
also okay speaking of unplayable can I
take a three year or is f3 an issue I
should play Knight c3 em I think I can
take I think I can take the pawn his
back rang is weak
the check benoni is not so bad it's it's
a it's a decent opening against a very
technically focused players because it's
purely strategic in nature okay yeah i
was thinking 92 and now i don't know hmm
yeah it's hard to keep the upon but i
have to play moose so let's play it's
going there actually okay well here i
can maybe oh that's the move I didn't
see at all mmm check check take on g2
that could be risky risky business hmm
and i don't want to i mean this is this
is for fun anyway this this kind of
session so let's try if I can do more
here King g3 is made so he has to go to
everyone here or this one okay so rook
takes is losing stuff and Knight takes
probably losing stuff as well
hmm yeah like 96 is very dry but still
hmm yeah I wonder I can't perpetual him
92 rook takes 93 but maybe I can play
this forward Knight takes a night f5
it's a bit risky but I just got 96
actually
plane we have to form 89 h 6 f king edge
aid interesting Brooksie one made now
coming up possibly sorry for not giving
any commentary it's kind of tricky
disposition now you can draw here I have
to have to accept it okay it's trying to
play on time being completely nuts lost
now but now okay it's been a long time
ok ok anyway so that was kind of bad to
lose because I was better than better
the whole time anyway I have to get into
the right gear of those games again i'm
playing motzko somewhat um ok I play him
a lot in those in those sessions he's
playing that that wacky benoni that
snake be known here none of this time
playing for Queens gambit interesting so
what is he doing there the classical
Queens gambit uh-huh ok I don't mind
that
I also don't mind the snake benoni I'm
just surprised that is not going for as
usual opening okay so i can easily
develop hmm interesting interesting eat
it tries to trade a little bit here i
think i want to avoid this straight and
centralize the night now let's see maybe
it's going 27 here roop the one that go
from there
yeah there are probably a couple of
questions right in there when I was in
that time scramble against the player
before sorry if I couldn't answer them
it's sometimes tricky to follow the chat
and and play at the same time I can
actually rearrange my ok Queen to e7
yeah I think rookie one is the most
obvious move I think I'm doing that ok
black plants in the cards bed structure
is a question by fours aquatica well
Black has a couple of ideas you can use
the e4 square sometimes for the base of
a king side attack your natural place on
the King side sometimes you can also
play on the queenside if white is
screwing up the minority attack it
depends a lot on some some concrete
concrete things it's hard to put into
into something that would work would
work all the time so c5 I cannot take c5
I can take this 74 simplifications I was
thinking that this could be an idea
let's try for this
yeah nice coming to d6
yeah the natural playing space for black
and the counts but it's the Kings side
but it is very dependent on some
specifics it's not something that is the
same all the time okay it looks kind of
nice this position but how to continue I
think maybe like this and Bishop H form
can be interesting it looks like quite a
decent position and I've actually have
one time that's helpful
the highest rated German players
probably Nissa piano or maybe got Maya
they're probably not so far away um any
the question about the candidates
tournament um anybody that I would like
to win hmm young I have a pretty clear
opinion I would and this is a kind of
off awful because I actually think that
that V she is probably maybe the nicest
guy of all the bunch don't let I have
anything against somebody there in
particular so what I would like to win I
would like someone else to win then then
vishy anand simply together a different
match playing them yeah him playing
cards and again feels kind of boring ok
so maybe just age 5 him actually or not
my taking is also good ok aronian would
be a good to good challenger definitely
he's an interesting person you know it's
also quite good for marketing purposes
and he's also very interesting and kind
of unpredictable creative player so it
would be a cool match but there are many
many many interesting matches possible
ok so what about this um I'm in this
diagonal night f5 is it taking this it
looks terrible for black maybe it isn't
i know let's play it
hm
I can take check on his seven right take
on c6 I'm winning the house here mr.
Mott school somewhat yeah okay resigns
okay so let's no look at them and check
and the chat yeah there's a question was
John Stockton would have a
recommendation on understanding porn
struck just sometimes I say that this or
that move does not make sense in the
structure and I'm left wondering why
sometimes yeah this is very general it i
mean it's it's based on experience and
something that i have just learned over
the years by studying games or whatever
it really depends a lot on the
particular structure I to explain why I
think it doesn't make any sense but some
kind of limit what you can do in a video
that is not supposed to be so long here
we have a the Leningrad variation of
them of the NIMS oh interesting line I'm
forgetting my own book again but i think
i'm still on track this is what i have
in my in my recommendation the names
will be no knee
yeah I will probably due to some chest
tempo some chest tempo tactics trainer
video or some kind of some kind of
tactics training video but it's it's
hard to predict at the moment because I
have many things on my plate that are
not actually in totally chess related
and therefore it's hard to plan at the
moment let's see if I can get one of
them one of the bishops
that book porn structures a grand master
guide by Del Rio is it Del Rio isn't it
Rios florencio Rios or something like
that I'm not so good with names
sometimes Yaga Ginsu I saw that comment
about how to analyze your own games but
did you see my reply I reply to that I
have a problem I don't know what to what
software to use for that the the ICC
software has its limit form for
analyzing the games and I don't want to
use chessbase yeah b5 is something but I
can still play that I'm playing by the
way you know Mario know that sounds like
a cool name and I just had played p5 lo
and behold I call it in yeah the
important thing is that here it's
difficult for wire to play a form
because f4 beacons so you actually reply
to my reply that's cool yeah maybe I
find some idea then I am did not manage
to to look at this yet ok hmm what to do
here let's put this back
yellow to internet chess club here
unhone your channel we are the last
person standing here for on Twitch
everybody else's on YouTube we aren't
which now i really want to go to youtube
streaming but I had absolutely no time
to try to figure that out it's a not
easy at the mode that Luke tries to go
over to e7 activating it like that and
i'm playing quickly Oh risk giving me
the square that's cool i love my night
on c4 ok i don't know if i want to take
i think i'll do take yeah this idea of
study the catalan instead of Queens
gambit declined and Enzo to save a
little bit of time and effort is not
completely wrong I think it's a bit
easier to study the Catalan then the
whole body of theory of those other two
openings it's a little bit less work but
it depends a lot on what kind of
opposition what kind of a position you
face not honor on a higher level but on
a normal level I think it still is
easier to play the Catalan so what is
this he's trying to break through there
with he five and maybe he can maybe he
can actually or does he have some
brilliant discovery cm maybe
and that nylon see for the end is not
doing that much somehow it's not doing
that much Jeff hey we have to take on c3
and even my advantage in time has
somewhat dwindled down
is there some way to avoid the cat alone
if you play something light f6e 65 based
with black not really yeah I'm not so
happy with with this but at least that
seems to be playable whoa he's getting
fancy b6 what is this ok I want to take
it with the rook yeah well the Catalan
is against Knight f6 e65 stuff you don't
have to play the field keto variation of
the gruenfelder or the king's indian
necessarily you don't have to copy all
of what mr. eric is presenting in his
repertoire it's probably too much work
anyway um okay what about this I don't
have a good square for that bloody piece
maybe have to go to be too and I don't
want to I don't want to okay at least
hear you cannot play you five as f 5 is
hanging 293 is interesting okay so he
wants to play five anyway
Jim much that I can do I cannot even
take this bloody porn Wow
yeah that it looks bad but what to do at
least it seems to cause some problems
yeah Magnus game against alien off was
great there was a great game against the
Catalan
so I I have to grab stuff him it's down
to 20 something seconds maybe I have
escaped them his center is falling apart
may I'm still in trouble but I feel like
it was worse earlier night coming to e6
as a problem
wow that's almost made them it's going
age for then oh holy hell what the heck
yeah 97 unbelievable stuff I you know
sometime well I was lucky there was
lucky who what the doc did I do that it
was kind of a crazy game I don't know
what happened anyway that's let's go for
a new one um I wouldn't say someone a
cat rocket moose as is it fair to say
that the Catalan isn't very ambitious
you know do you get much in the Queens
gambit to client these days I don't
think you do so it is viable very viable
okay what can I do against lb i'm going
to go E for ya my 1.e4 serve of the of
the evening let's play an open society I
usually don't do well in those but it
probably makes for a decent TV hangers
oh I think this is kind of nice
mmm I want to play the night to euphoria
Bishop c5 looking weird to be honest
like he's running into nightly form
can't play a for yeah that's that's bad
I should have seen this this coming okay
okie one then so what now 24 was one
thing that I was looking at and I'm
going for that I have a bad feeling
about this for black 95 there's Queen g7
and over so what is this move there g6
now castles Oh is he going to Castle
long here
if I mean okay I'm not taking on G sound
not even thinking about it yeah now i'm
going to open up the queenside
I hope to switch to YouTube next week if
I have the time to figure it out
it's kind of unpredictable because well
as I mentioned on this stream I'm
switching to a new and new apartment to
live in and this is this proves to be a
kind of a hassle to do the switch
because all kinds of handyman have to do
things like changing the plumbing wiring
some electrical stuff whatever and it's
a it all takes a bit more time than I
was thinking I would take so i have to
be at the place do things whatever and
it makes the whole thing kind of
unpredictable more than what i'm doing
at what time so um anyway what is this
he wants to go age five them and this is
not totally it's not to be
underestimated actually at age five
stuff a queen doesn't have a very clear
good square to go to
and maybe go them prevent it like that
yeah I'm not completely happy with this
but I couldn't really see anything
anything better at the time 95 I thought
Bishop f4 even though even though he has
night a three check which can be could
be an argument i also got Bishop tea for
my all kinds of things are possible him
we should f4 Knight f3 check that isn't
great it actually isn't great can you
believe that
ok I have to do something I cannot
cannot take any longer so Bishop is six
just taking things now here I think
Knight f3 I can also just take and
rookie 5 next or Bishop f4 maybe even
I think rookie five should work after
Luke g8 you never check there as well
and then Bishop you three that should be
relatively clear using the pen and I'm a
full look up so
now probably some c58 Roger I take up
take 80 for that doesn't work at all
night i love most basically
ok so how to do this maybe this sent one
unpin I don't know maybe you can go back
to the eighth-ranked and pick up the
bishop like that it wasn't the most
intelligent move ever and still go rupee
and Queen f7 what kind of move was that
anyway here openings for non-title
players are not of essential importance
but it is important that you at least
stay out of trouble if you if you play
very ambitious openings and dangerous
things dangerous for yourself then it
can be a problem if you know not that
not that much and yet then you have to
settle for some easier to learn things
ok it's not such a bad session I'm I'm
scoring ok I'm not playing well but I'm
scoring ok
yeah have you ever crested a new game
but didn't get one yet
I praying against group isn't that cool
I've made a video on the group on the
grope and actually get it isn't that
cool that's funny d for here this is
also possible wow I mean I can probably
still play for I recommended this kind
of position with with h3 being played I
wonder who takes takes takes takes Queen
B 3 B should be six back I shouldn't
spend so much time
yeah I spend too much time him him
giving him 20 seconds this is a bit much
okay let's see what we can do about is
pawn structure there
trying to play night at five the tech is
d4 pawn yeah if I if I get to a tech is
father I can also take on c4 the whole
time grabby floor but I felt that this
is a good strategic decision just
playing normal normal kind of moves that
same
playing playing main lines is in general
not a bad idea ok I'm going to I'm going
to suck a piece there and go for some
fun stuff him and see what happens ok um
it's really a vacuum edition maybe be
five or something I can also just castle
I go for be five
in general I I agree that going from
main lines is a good idea there are main
lines for a reason and it I mean things
we should not totally neglect them the
virtue of off sidelines especially if
you find interesting new ideas in those
sidelines why not why not go for them
but in general looking at main lines has
a big advantage they are better at the
sidelines a plan of 97 g 6 h-4 is that's
something to look into against the group
you don't don't look into anything with
this opening you just you just play your
game it's it's never it's it's so he
rarely happening that it doesn't make
sense to to invest lots of time i mean i
did this video serious on on the rare
openings but it's not like you need to
spend ages on on this kind of stuff ok
so I'm going to just push the queenside
his whole position is a mess I'm not
sure that it is actually that bad it's
just a mess
yeah what to do here I was thinking a
three years a move but not totally sure
yeah i'm going through oh it felt like
it i'm running a little bit out of steam
IAM a little bit maybe i can just take
after beat eggs actually hmm interesting
what i use that that's not that's not on
night takes just seven what is this okay
i'm taking me to that's not going to
work ever for white I don't believe it
giving me to two connected passos hear
that that's crazy yeah I know he wants
to check made me on g7 I figured that
much but I can take there was check and
take h3 with check and I can go d for I
think I good d 4 here just just block
that diagonal okay what the what the
beep if I got three Queens I've got
three Queens on the board that's amazing
can I keep the three Queen somehow it's
probably difficult to do Bishop yet and
now he resigned oh my goodness I cannot
remember having three Queens after 28
moves oh my god that was one of the
wackiest games ever okay I'm going for a
new game oh and after all that I get mr.
gold moon tiara wow that is Grandmaster
roost em off pretty strong GM let's see
what he what he does him I don't know
Bishop edge for that much so I'm going
for Bishop f4
no I'm playing a London type of setup
mmm yeah I don't like the London so much
it against the against the Dutch but
we'll see how to how this plays out
looks a bit passive one problem is that
yeah after efore is got f4 and then my
bishop looks really silly and maybe I
can actually do this that looks a bit
more and a little bit better okay
goodnight g6 here
Bishop g2g one vision of sin ig6 winning
a rock hmm so it is giving me the rook
gimme gimme position is still kind of
kind of wacky Queen f3 is a very nice
resource that I actually could have
played that move ah queena three would
have been very interesting attacking us
bishop and attacking b7 I mean this is
still in this this is still possible
okay I mean age seven I am yeah I'll
take the rook mighty will castle yes
still-still interesting we should G for
a hot
hmm what a weird position I really
getting completely bonkers position
today positions what to do I'd like to
prevent him from castling should be fire
this Bishop g7 okay at least that
prevents canceling maybe I should have
just taken I know why Cannot takes his
seven I have no idea what's going on
I mean the thing is why it is probably
much better but the position is so crazy
d4 Knight f6 9036 g3 be five is good
yeah that's a good line you can play
that you should probably know it better
than I do but it is a good line
okie dokie g-form
Wow
trying for quincy for a Quincy 46 what a
mess
I guess I'm f 294 check maybe 94 is
actually a move I mean queen is 627 am i
winning they i'm not sure and f2 is is a
threat it should be three maybe yeah
it's going for that for that stuff
Bishop g3 looks awfully slow but I don't
see a movie at the moon
i can probably take g3t h8 as sick as it
looks
I have even Bishop t6 is playable him
now maybe bishop maybe bishop hy don't
know Wow
what is happening here Queen before I
don't know what's going on I'm a rock up
please let me be winning other than
everything else would be entirely unfair
it really would be but maybe it's just
somehow killing me here okay so he
threatened to know 93 I'm taking his
rook
I cannot calculate this oh my goodness
this is how this is made actually okay I
have to go here and then f2 were
unbelievable crap that's unbelievable
crap unbelievable what he did him so I
take it I'm still a look up i'm still a
look up but i have no time no wait night
check can go to the one
can you believe this nonsense he won he
won that rook back unbelievable great
stuff and now he's two pawns up in a
bloody rook endgame I was one of the one
of the wackiest games have played in
ages being the whole board up basically
now one on time I think that is actually
correct result I mean it was probably
locked down a million in this game I
couldn't figure it out I don't know what
happened to you it's simply don't know
who
I have no idea if this game it looked
like there should be a win for white
somehow but it was so bonkers the French
Labrador neighbor eh I even didn't know
that this existed g-46 f4 it's probably
playable away i think didn't I camera
play that against Yassa saravanan in one
of the u.s. championships it's probably
okay to just get to get some game going
but I cannot really tell you about the
objective merits you so what do we have
here we have a hedgehog here against
Italian 5 you tell you I am what is the
sky 1 y el bulli is the name that is not
somebody I know okay this is one of the
lines that have some experience and I
usually go with F for Queenie reroute d1
so I'm not going to waste much time here
mr. bully if you don't know that line
there's something lacking in your
knowledge about the Hedgehog it's not so
bad for white then an old favorite of
rib Lee and Wolf under sons and cap off
and so on so it's not not like
completely out of the picture but
interesting player with by by Italian
five he wants to get in b5 that's the
that's the clear idea and maybe nine to
six interesting
very interesting
I know this is very risky but I mean the
games today was so backe heck okay i
would get into a solid position anyway
it seems
yeah black has a couple of options also
some d5 based things d5 I go g5 so but
the White King position is very very
dicey looking that was my idea to get
this in I don't have I don't know about
the objective merits but it looks
interesting I can't i just take you will
take with the porn i guess night takes
95 is unbearable so take with a pawn mmm
so if i get an f5 i will have good a
good control of a d5 so i'm shooting for
that yeah that's dangerous for Black
Knight g 60 ever ha I didn't look at
this at all hmm ok you're not just six
at least has a clear threat in a cage
for winning everything what you can play
such a non-move here that's hard to
believe I'm threatening f6 here that's
dangerous
and cream v7s is not really on I have 94
for example that looks that looks lost
actually 95 Queen f7 that's a disaster
okay I should should I I just should not
blunder the Queen don't blunder the
Queen number one thing to take into
account um yo Queen to have 70
maybe I should start with 95 mm my lip
be easier it really might have been
easier okay um night you for maybe
yeah I didn't play that so great I think
he's kind of still alive and that
shouldn't shouldn't be the case
it's never playing who I expect to be
five like nothing else nothing happens
here
like no very in the world they will also
lose on time I guess okay maybe I should
have taken d6 actually and okay I'm kind
of relaxed here it's got 28 seconds and
even though I probably missed a couple
of killed this looks like look still
looks pretty bad ok so and I know Queen
g4 please
whoa that was not my plan 96 year that
was not my plan really screwed that up
it's got queen of 5 coming up and now he
plays good moves after all those weird
moose
I screwed that up royally I know I have
to really find moves here unbelievable
Queen f3 is got four seconds left
I don't know come on
I Scott quindi for check and I will run
on time but that was really awful I was
really awful from that completely
completely winning position screwing
this up to just win on time anyway been
a long day ok i hope you enjoyed the
show some wacky games i had a game with
three queens in the group opening never
c never saw that before so i hope it was
a good a good show to watch hope you
liked it yeah i'll be back next next
week not sure if it will be on twitch or
YouTube I hope it's YouTube but it's not
the ever managed so hope you enjoyed the
the whole thing bye bye